armin láser este es el nombre del nuevo
presidente de la unión
cristianodemócrata alemana el partido
hegemónico en el país germano desde la
primera victoria electoral de angela
merkel en 2005 la set de 59 años y
considerado como centrista sucede aa
negret camps code en bagua al frente del
partido tras imponerse a pie derecho
mets y norbert röttgen en un congreso
formado por mil un delegado de todo el
país presidente del estado federado de
renania del norte westfalia el más
poblado del país es un político cercano
a angela merkel y se espera que continúe
con el camino centrista que comenzó la
actual canciller alemana exponga mets y
yousaf ago traigo experiencia de
gobierno liderazgo de un gran estado
federal balance entre diferentes
intereses y algo que quizás no hace daño
en un líder de la cdu el hecho de haber
ganado ya unas elecciones estuvo mensual
en ibadán nexia porque las elecciones de
este año son cruciales para el futuro de
nuestro país quiero que la sede tenga
también desde septiembre responsabilidad
de gobierno para ello mucho y para ello
estoy preparado
in this page sin embargo tendrá que
enfrentar la presión del ala derecha del
partido que considera ese centrismo como
culpable de la fuga de votantes hacia el
ultraderechista alternativa por alemania
la pregunta ahora es si las set será el
futuro candidato del partido para las
elecciones presidenciales de septiembre
la figura del candidato debe ser
consensuada con su partido hermano de
baviera la csi y la pandemia elevó el
perfil de otros candidatos como el
ministro de salud quien se espa o el
ministro presidente de baviera marcus
soda por el momento algunas encuestas
indican que los alemanes no lo ven como
un buen canciller para el país tendrá de
plazo hasta marzo o abril para convencer
de lo contrario a su partido